are you ready to unleash the power of
azure and embark on a transformative
journey into the world of cloud
computing Azure Basics is your gateway
to harnessing the immense potential of
this Cutting Edge technology by
leveraging Azure you'll Propel your
business to new heights of efficiency
scalability and Innovation Asha isn't
just a buzzword it's a game changer with
its seamless blend of flexibility and
cost Effectiveness Azure revolutionizes
The Way businesses operate so say
goodbye to Hefty infrastructure cost and
hello to unlimited storage on demand
resources and lightning fast processing
speeds did you know that Microsoft Azure
has captured a significant share of the
global Cloud Market reaching an
astounding 150 dollars billion in
Revenue by 2023 that's right Azure is
leading the charge in the cloud
computing landscape and the
opportunities are Limitless for for
those who sees them but Azure is more
than just impressive numbers it's a
gateway to Endless Possibilities from
startups to multinational corporations
organizations of all sizes are embracing
Azure to accelerate their digital
transformation Journey streamline
operations and enhanced customers
experiences now let's talk about the
figures that matter Azure professionals
are earning top dollar salaries with
entry-level positions commanding an
impressive range of seventy thousand
dollars to one twenty thousand dollars
as you gain expertise and experience you
can unlock even more lucrative
opportunities in this rapidly expanding
field so if you're ready to embark on
this exciting career path look no
further than simply learns Catholic
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into the cloud
architecture deployment model security
and migration strategies X explore
platforms like AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform to build your
Cloud expertise don't miss out on this
chance to transform your career and join
the ranks of successful Azure
professionals click the link in the
description to discover more about the
cloud computing course here's an
inspiring success stories from Arts
satisfied Learners who have unlocked the
full potential of azure the future is in
the cloud and it's waiting for you to
seize it unleash the magic of cloud
computing and its platforms like AWS
Azure and gcp and witnessed the
floodgates open as your website attracts
a tidal wave of organic traffic and
enjoys unrivaled success in the digital
realm hey I am
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech homestamp video that with this
course I had the choice to study while I
can't understand that is how I got this
new job offer with 60 salary high in
Finland I will be leading the cloud
computing unit of my new haircut we
cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are awesome let's get started
with the video saira is a country singer
and recently she got sponsored by North
American Music company for her new album
she was really nervous and excited about
the performance once all songs were
recorded she was set to release the
album worldwide
so when she inquired about when it would
happen she realized she barely had one
week left
she panicked and ran to the manager of
that Music Company Mark to inquire how
everything like editing mixing
portfolios and promotions would be done
in just one week
that's when Mark answered don't you
worry our production is managed on
Microsoft Azure Cyrus confused and asked
but isn't Azure a cloud service used to
store your data Mark smiled and answered
well it's true but Azure is not just
that but much more let me explain it to
you mark further explained that
Microsoft Azure is an open and flexible
Cloud platform for services such as
analytics virtual Computing storage
networking and more it offers a
constantly growing selection of products
and services designed to satisfy all of
your demands on a single practical
platform it enables its users to engage
in cloud computing and is designed to
manage tasks through Microsoft's data
centers a data center is a structure
with networked computers storage systems
and computational infrastructure that
organizations like us use to gather
process store and distribute massive
amounts of data
upon learning what Azure is used for she
was still unsure how it would help her
in the album release
Mark explained that in Azure every
production happens simultaneously every
day Azure builds Mission critical
solutions to analyze images comprehend
speech and make predictions using data
simultaneously hence multitasking he
further added that all the data of her
album for example footage and audio
travel securely to the cloud from even
the most remote locations all the data
is securely stored in the cloud which
can easily be accessed by the editors
and other production members immediately
on realizing every process would run in
parallel Cyrus was under the impression
that all this would be a tedious and
time-consuming job then Mark answered no
only the data relevant to their role
would be accessible to them same
platform same tools same workflow but
just more efficient and secure
Cyrus started wondering ask that it must
cost them a fortune to use such advanced
technology Mark further explained that
the costs are easily controllable so we
only pay for what we use and because our
album is stored in the cloud it's
accessible from every corner of the
world for example producers can review
approve and make changes in real time
and video indexing makes the album
searchable and understandable Predictive
Analytics makes the most of marketing
and distribution strategies therefore no
ad dollars are wasted or seats are left
empty
secure distribution means album releases
smoothly and on time as soon as the
audience starts watching and reacting to
every interaction Azure analyzes their
viewing habits to drive recommendations
advertising and personalization
this makes future production decisions
really easy
Zyra was relieved to understand this new
technology and how it would help her
build her future career
Azure is the best public cloud service
available today thanks to its speed
flexibility and affordability as well as
its features and pricing today some of
the biggest companies in the world like
eBay Boeing Samsung and BMW are now
using the Microsoft Azure infrastructure
and the support they require for their
better production and performance
when it comes to cloud service providers
Microsoft azure's adaptability is
proving to be a valuable quality that
makes it a good choice in the healthcare
manufacturing consumer Appliance travel
Aviation and entertainment sectors so no
what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so Azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
Microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services now
resources and services are nothing but
you know you can store your data and you
can transform the data using services
that Microsoft provides again all you
need is the internet and being able to
connect to the Azure portal then you get
access to all of the resources and their
services in case you want to know more
about how it's different from its rival
which is AWS I suggest you click on the
top right corner and watch the AWS
versus Azure video so that you can
clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
that you need to know about Azure it was
launched in February 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when AWS was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like I
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through Azure and one
of the most important selling points is
that 80 percent of Fortune 500 companies
use as your services which means that
most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using Azure and
then Azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the C sharp
node.js Java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now Azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54 now let's talk
about Azure Services now Azure Services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute a machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that Azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute Services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of Linux or Windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add RAM you can decrease RAM you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a matter of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by Azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by Azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azure CDN or the content delivery
Network now the Azure CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have expressr now
with this you can actually connect your
on-premise network onto the Microsoft
cloud or any of the services that you
want through a private connection so the
only communication that happens is
between your on-premise network and the
service that you want then you have
virtual Network now with virtual Network
you can have any of the Azure Services
communicate with each other in a secure
manner in a private manner next we have
Azure DNS so Azure DNS is a hosting
service which allows you to host their
DNS or domain name system domains in
Azure so you can host your application
using Azure DNS now for these storage
Services first up we have disk storage
with this storage you are given a cost
effective option of using HDD or solid
state drives to go along with your
virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the
SMB protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have queue
storage now with Q storage you can
provide durable message queuing for an
extremely large workload and the most
important part is that this can be
accessed from anywhere in the world now
let's talk about how Azure can be used
firstly for application development it
could be any application mostly web
applications then you can test the
application see how well it works you
can host the application on the internet
you can create virtual machines like I
mentioned before with the service you
can create these virtual Machines of any
size or Ram that you want you can
integrate In Sync features you can
collect select and store matrices for
example how the data Works how the
current data is how you can improve upon
it all of that is possible with these
services and your virtual hard drives
which is an extension of the virtual
machines where these services are able
to provide you a large amount of storage
where data can be stored so the wide
variety of services available on Azure
includes artificial intelligence plus
machine learning plus analytic services
to get and or to give us a good visual
of how the data or how the application
is performing or the type of the
category of data stored and to read from
the logs and variety of compute Services
different VMS with different size and
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us and
identity service to manage our users in
the Azure cloud and and those users can
be integrated or Federated with let's
say Google Facebook you know LinkedIn so
there are some external Federation
Services they can be used to integrate
with our identity system iot's iot
Services iot tools and Technologies
available and management tools to manage
the users you know creating identities
one and then managing them on top of it
is a totally different thing and we have
tools Technologies to manage the users
cool services for a data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
Technologies available for mobile
application a development and I can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking Services I can Implement my
own security both Azure provider and
third-party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the Azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged ident the solution
meaning integration with active
directory in the cloud or an on-premises
and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
Azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment inside azure's Cloud
environment that too in a virtual
private Network now we will talk about
virtual private Network at a later point
but as of now just know that there are a
lot of services available in Azure
compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of computer options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on-premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
soft software attached to it or do we
want to go and buy the operating system
from the cloud from Azure Marketplace
and these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these complete
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pair for what we use
model meaning there is no upfront cost
we use the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal or long term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a paper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
paper minute building model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now bad service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or Linux it's going to run fairly well
and with bad service we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
Azure batch service is actually runs on
a large scale parallel and high
performance Computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in Azure
and when we run batch services this
Azure batch creates a pool of computer
nodes and installs the needed
applications that we want to run and
then it schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually can use the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and the networking
services that we would be using for this
batch serves let's summarize this bad
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be queues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this bad service
helps us to manage the application
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
microservices no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scales that it lets us to create
a group of identical load balanced VMS I
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced VMS the number of instances or
the number of VM instances in an in a
scale set can increase or decrease in
response to the demand or in response to
a schedule that we Define you know the
resources needed on a Monday morning is
not the same as that would be required
on a Saturday or a Sunday morning all
right and even within the day the
resources that would be needed in the
beginning of the business hour is not
the resources that would be needed now
at noon or you know after eight or nine
in the evening so the demands could
actually vary in environment and this
skill set helps us to take care of the
varying demand or take care of the
different infrastructure requirement at
a different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
High availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like I said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes other requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machine with virtual machine
scale said we can centrally manage and
configure and update a big group of VMS
and it's a great use case when it comes
to Big Data or container workloads as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about cloud services now this Azure
cloud service is actually a platform as
a service and it's very friendly in fact
it is designed for applications that
support scalability or an application
that requires scalability or reliability
and and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so Azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platformed as a service so here is how
you got to be thinking with
infrastructure as a service like VMS we
first create and configure the
environment and then we run applications
on top of it let's look the
responsibility the responsibility for us
in VM is that we manage everything end
to end like uh you know deploying new
patches picking the versions of the
operating system and making sure they
are intact and all that stuff it's all
managed by us but on the contrary with
platform as a service it's I mean it's
as if the environment is already ready
all that you have to do is deploy your
application in it and manage the
platform I mean manage the platform not
as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by Azure
like you know deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all handled by
the Azure so we deploy the application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
Azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can write the application code
and we don't have to worry about
Hardware simply hand over the code and
cloud service takes care of it so no
worry on the the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something crashes how do I
update the infrastructure how do I
manage the maintenance or the downtime
in the underlying infrastructure all
that is handled by Azure it also
provides a good testing environment for
us you know we can simply run the code
test it before it's actually released to
the production I want to expand a bit on
these testing applications so this Azure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging envelope
government where we can add more to it
and then swap it back at a later point
so it kind of gives us in swappable
environment for testing our applications
and not only that it gives us Health
monitoring alerts it helps us to monitor
the health and availability of our
application and there is a dashboard we
can benefit from when we use Azure cloud
services and that shows the key
statistics all in one place and we can
also set up real-time alerts to one when
a service availability or a certain
metrics that we are concerned about
degrades as next thing in compute domain
let's talk about functions now functions
are serverless Computing and many times
if you heard about Azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
Computing or Azure functions which is a
serverless Computing service hosted on
Microsoft Azure the main motive of a
function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running that code and the
best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what is azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is C Sharp F sharp node.js the Java and
PHP so here we really don't have to
worry about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes Azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in Azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a Docker
swarm cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one Computing
environment to another it could be a
testing to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on premises to
cloud or One Cloud to another Cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the VM and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the VMS or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers they can be
deployed into the cloud using a single
command if you're using command line
interface and a couple of button clicks
if we are using the Azure portal and
these containers are kept lightweight
but they are equally secure as virtual
machines let's talk about container
service as next thing the container
service or or sometimes called as Azure
kubernetes service it helps us to manage
the containers containers one thing and
a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them now
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that at the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and ACS also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that a
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this AKs
helps us to simplify that environment
all right as next thing in contain in a
domain let's talk about container
registry we spoke about registry a
little bit when we spoke about Docker
images so container registry is a single
place where we can store our images
which are Docker images when we use when
we use containers it's it's Docker
images that we use for our image
purposes so these container images are a
central registry that can be used to
ease container development by easing the
storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like Docker swarm are the images
used in Docker swarm or in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these Geo replication and it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geo replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images will have provisioned at the
global application so one edit
replication and then provosting of the
applications Global wide and this
replication also helps us to helps us
Network latency because you know anytime
an application needs to deploy it does
not have to rely on a single source
which which can be reached only through
high latency Network because we have
Global replications around the world
anytime the application wants to check
back it will check back uh the
application which is in a very nearby
location for the application itself
Global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe has next thing in a
learning let's talk about Azure
databases now this Azure databases are a
rational in fact they have many flavors
in them we're going to look at different
uh flavors so SQL nosql cache type of
database that Azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or we're
going to learn one by one so this Azure
SQL database is a rational database in
fact it's a rational database as a
service it's managed by Azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a rational database as a service
based on Microsoft SQL Server database
engine and this database is a high
performance database it's very Bible and
it's very secure as well and this High
reliability high performance and for
this high security you really don't have
to do anything it comes along with it
and it's managed by Azure and there are
two things that I definitely need to
mention about Azure SQL database that is
it's an intelligent service number one
it's fully managed by Azure and it also
has this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in many of
the other Cloud providers that I'm aware
of so I thought I'll mention it so it
uses built-in intelligence to learn
about the user's database patterns and
helps improve performance and protection
and migration or importing data is very
easy when it comes to Azure SQL database
so it can be readily or immediately used
for analytic reporting and intelligent
applications in Azure as next thing
let's talk about Azure Cosmo DB now
Azure Cosmo DB is a database service
that is for nosql type and it's it's
created to provide low latency and an
application that scales dynamically or
that scales rapidly now this Azure
cosmodb is an a globally distributed
service
and it's a multi-modal database this can
be provisioned in a click of a button
that's all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure cosmodb in the Azure
it helps with scaling the database now
we can elastically and independently
scale throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the Azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and it
provides our Azure promises a
comprehensive SLA that no other database
can offer that's the best part about
cosmodb so this Cosmo DB was built with
a global distribution in mind and it's
built with the horizontal scale in mind
and all this we can use by only paying
for what we have used and remember the
difference between Azure Cosmo DB and
the SQL database is that Azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas SQL doesn't all
right few other things about Azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph column family and document
data it also gives users a number of AP
options like SQL JavaScript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check in the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that R alright let's talk
about redis cache discussion about Azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about redist cash now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now redis
cache is based on and a popular open
source caching product which is redis
sometimes called as there is cash now
what's the use case it's typically used
to Cache to improve the performance and
scalability of a system that rely
heavily on back-end data stores now
performance when we use redis cache is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis Cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as a
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this various cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
height throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this various cache is actually backed by
Reddit server and it supports a string
hashes linked list and various other
data structures now let's talk about
security and identity Services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's a principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the specialty about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and security accident from happening so
let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity G management are
Azure security center now this Azure
security Center provides Security
Management and threat protection across
the workloads in both cloud and in the
hybrid environment it helps control user
access and application control to stop
any malicious activity if present it
helps us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
server is in security and identity would
be keyboard now a key vault is a service
or a feature that help Safeguard the
cryptographic keys and any other Secrets
used by the cloud applications and the
services in other words this Azure key
vault is a tool for securely storing and
accessing the secrets of the environment
I mean the secret Keys now a secret is
anything that you really want to have a
very tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyword is now key vault is
used in Secrets management it's helped
in securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management and what really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about the certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy pop public
and private SSL TLS certificates in
Azure and lot more so in a nutshell this
key wall it provides users the ability
to provision new walls and keys in just
a matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now Azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
Services Plus application access
management plus identity protection and
and one good thing about this Azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
does Azure active directory is going to
behave now this Azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
Cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this Azure active directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our Cloud environment it
also provides good Security Solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data now that we have
discussed about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that Azure has to offer Azure provides
built-in management and account
governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on-premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build a disaster
recoveries it also helps in applying
policies and conditions to automate our
environment we use Azure management
tools and it's also used in cost control
methods so this Azure management plays a
wide role across the Azure services and
in the management tools first comes the
Azure advisor now this Azure advisor it
acts as a guide to educate us about
Azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that will happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations or first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not Parts it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provided are very easy
to follow very easy to implement and see
results you can think of azure advisor
as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azura advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps in improve the performance
security High availability of our
environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure use message and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment and next in the list would
be Network Watcher now this network
Watcher helps users identify and gain
insights in the overall Network
performance and the health of the
overall environment now these Azure
Watchers provides enough tools to
monitor to diagnose to view the metrics
and to enable or disable logs which
means regenerate and collect the logs
for resources in the Azure virtual
Network so with network Watcher can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a VM or in a
database you know but just looking at
the logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our Network we can
again a lot of insight to the current
Network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network Watcher offers it also helps in
investigating VPN connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and our end stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the the
list would be Microsoft Azure portal now
this Microsoft Azure portal it provides
a single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using Azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the Azure portal
and this Azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on teams spends based on days
spends based on Department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual offer where the money is spending
or where is the bill consumed within the
Azure environment next in the list would
be Azure a resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual Network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
Azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure results
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision or deployed at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources a
lot better resource Group also is used
to control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across hybrid environments it provides a
cloud-based Automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non-azure environments as
well which is on-premises so some of the
automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete control during the
deployment operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error-free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application so
let's expand on this the content
delivery network is actually a
distributed network of servers that can
efficiently deliver web content to users
now cdns are we going to use the word
CDN here cdns store cached content on
global Edge servers also called as pops
point of presence locations that are
very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking multiple copy
of the data and storing it in different
parts of the world and whoever is
requesting it the data gets delivered to
them from a server which is very locally
to them so this CDN offers developers a
global solution for rapidly delivering
high bandwidth content to users by
caching the content in a strategically
placed location which is very near to
them so these content delivery networks
it really helps in handling that's one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very efficiently and we can
also run analytic against the logs that
gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the results first and
then you only pay for what you have used
the next one in networking would be
expressed route now express route is
actually circuit or a link that provides
an a direct private connection to Azure
and because it's direct it gives low
latency link to Azure it gives good
speed and reliability for the Azure data
transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
in service that actually provides a
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different co-location
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the the internet because
it's fast because it's reliable because
it has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on-premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or at the
performance now these virtual private
Cloud these Express routes can be used
for taking backups if assume a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on-premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these Express routes can be
used not only to backup but also recover
the data because it provides good speed
low latency recurring the data is going
to be a lot sooner the next product or
service or we're gonna discuss in
networking is azure DNS now Azure DNS
allows us to host domain name in Azure
and these domain names come with an
exceptional performance and availability
now Azure DNS is used to set up and
manage DNS zones and records for our
domain name in the cloud now this Azure
DNS is a service for DNS just like the
name says and it provides name
resolution by using azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the DNS our cells
through the Azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a DNS provider
which does not even belong in RIT
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the DNS environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the DNS
in the very same Azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this Azure DNS very much integrates with
other DNA service providers it uses a
Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time all right
next in the list in networking Services
is virtual Network I'm sure this is
going to be very interesting and I'm
sure you're gonna like it so this
networking or virtual Network talking in
Azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this then this Azure
virtual Network helps us to provision
Azure virtual machines and it helps us
to securely communicate with other
on-premises and internet networks it
also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or Flows In and Out
of This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's winners that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision our vpns in the cloud so we
can connect the cloud and the
on-premises infrastructure and lot more
especially in a environment where we
have hybrid environment surely we will
be using virtual Network because that's
going to require a VPN for secure data
transfer in and out of the cloud and in
and out of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the Azure resources
the kind of logically stay in between or
logically stay within the Azure virtual
Network and here we can design the
network is given over to us you know you
can pick the IP you can pick the routing
you can pick the subnet and a lot of
freedom is given or I would say a lot of
control on how the network is designed
it's not like something that's already
cooked and we only get to use it no we
can actually build the network from the
scratch we can pick the IP address that
we like we can pick which subnet needs
to communicate with the other subnets
stuff like that and like I said if you
are using hybrid environment you
definitely would be requiring a virtual
Network because it helps connect the
on-premises and the cloud in a secure
fashion using VPN the last product we're
going to discuss and networking is a
load balancer this load balancer
actually provides application a good
availability and a good Network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
cross premises virtual networks with
Azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the back end pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now Azure storage in general is
a Microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
Azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes Azure data Lake it
includes Azure files as you see it it
includes Azure queues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
half storage to nearly 60 percent of how
much you would be actually spending
without using it so Azure simple storage
or store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on-premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around the hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running an hybrid environment is a
big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with Azure especially when it comes
to storage a lot of the things that
we're gonna see it clearly is designed
with hybrid environment in mind alright
so let's come back and talk about store
simple so store simple is an very
efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in Azure
Data Center and this store simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage sharing to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
use data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed to the cloud so you see
how this storage tiering automatically
happens in store simple and one another
cool feature of store simple is that it
enables us to create an on-demand and
scheduled backups of data and and then
store the data locally or in the cloud
and these backups are actually taken in
the form of of incremental snapshot
which means that they can be created and
restored quickly it's not a complete
backup it's an incremental backup and
these Cloud snapshots they can be
critically important when there is a
disaster and when there is a disaster
recovery scenario because these
snapshots can be called in and they can
be put on storage systems and then they
become the actual data so recovering is
faster if you have proper scheduled
backups or if you have frequent backups
and this storage simple it really helps
in easing our backup mechanism which
means it kind of eases our Disaster
Recovery steps or procedures as well so
the store simple it can be used to
automate data management data migration
data movement data tearing across the
Enterprise both in cloud and on-premises
it actually improves the compliance and
accelerates the disaster recovery for
our environment and if there is one
thing that's increasing every new day in
our environment that will be storage and
this stores simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much free
planning on storage is needed yes there
will be a need but not as much as I
would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data Lake store this data
Lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this is data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and other any injection speed and it
kind of collects them in one single
space or in one single place for
operational efficiency I mean
operational efficiency and for analytic
purpose Hadoop in Azure is very
dependent on this data Lake storage and
this data Lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using Hadoop in the cloud in
Azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the Right Storage to pick
would be data Lake store in Azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use Azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses Azure blob
storage behind the scenes for or global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for Azure
Cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
Azure blob storage is Microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for Rapid reads if I explain
to you on what scenarios we will be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many ID
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of Fetchers can fetch data
from Azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of Disaster
Recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud ID
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates an data a new version
gets created which means at any point I
can roll back as and when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable queues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workloads let's expand this
queue storage for a moment now this Q
storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through HTTP
and https calls a single queue or a
single Cube message can be up to like 24
KB in size and a single queue can
contain millions of such 24 KB in size
messages and how much can it hold it can
hold up to the total capacity of the
storage account account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate How much would
it hold and this Azure queue storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling in the application so you
know it's not very dependent or
sometimes it's not at all dependent on
the other application because now we
have a queue in between which kind of
translates or which kind of connects or
which kind of decouples both the
environment now we have a queue in
between both the environment can scale
up or scale down independently the next
in the storage service would be file
storage let's talk about file storage
now these Azure files provide secure
simple and managed Cloud file shares now
with file share in the cloud it actually
extends the user servers on-premises
performance and capacity and lot of
familiar tools for the cloud file share
management can be used along with the
file storage that we're talking about so
let's expand a bit on file storage now
this Azure files or Azure file storage
offers a fully managed file shares in
the cloud that can be accessed via the
SMB protocol server message block
protocol now this Azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible Linux is
compatible Mac OS is compatible in an
addition to all this being able to run
on on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on-premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
I would say that some Advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a nosql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with a
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of data it's a
lot cheaper when you compare it with the
traditional SQL data or data storage so
some of the things that we can store in
the table storage are are of course
they're going to be flexible data sheets
such as user data for web application
address books device information and
other types of metadata for our service
requirements and it can have any number
of tables up to the capacity limit of
the storage account now this is not
possible with SQL this is only possible
with nosql especially with table storage
in Azure explanation of storage really
concluded the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his ID
personal but this ID personal is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after this lengthy discussion and
his question was well there are a lot of
other Cloud providers available what
made you specifically choose Azure I
mean from the kind of question that he
asked we can say that he is very curious
and he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from a different angle
now so he started to explain what are
the capabilities or how Azure is better
than the competitor so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and I'm going to tell you
what the CEO told his ID person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by Microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is dotnet friendly
Azure supports the dotnet programming
language and it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and the new applications deployed
using.net programming framework so if
your application is dot net most of the
time you would end up picking Azure I
mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking Azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that Azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development life cycle which is an
industry leading Assurance process when
we buy services from Azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like I mentioned many times in the past
and I would like to mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of the cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the documentation it's picture rich
and the documentations are neat and
clear with really it would encourage you
to learn more it will encourage you to
think and imagine and try easily get a
grasp of how Services work so it has a
very gentle learning curve Azure allows
the utilization of technologies that
several business have used for years so
that is a big history behind it it has a
very gentle learning curve the
certifications the documentations the
stage by stage certification levels it's
all very gentle learning curve which is
generally missing in other clouds
service providers now this would really
impress the ctOS or people working in
finance and budgeting if an organization
is already using Microsoft software they
can definitely go and Avail or be bold
and ask for a discount that can reduce
the overall Azure spending in other
words overall a pricing of the Azure so
that's what helped or they are the
information that helped the CEO pick
Azure as his cloud service provider and
then the CEO goes on and talks about the
different companies that are currently
using Azure and they are definitely
using Azure for a reason like Pixar
Boeing Samsung EasyJet Xerox BMW 3M they
are major multinational multi-billion
companies they rely run operate their ID
in Azure and this CEO has a thought that
his it person is still not very
convinced unless and until he shows him
a visual of how easy things are in Azure
so he goes on and explains about a
practical application of azure which is
what exactly I'm going to show you as
well all right a quick project on
building an Azure app using or building
a dotnet application in Azure web app
and making it connect to an SQL database
will solidify all the knowledge that we
have gained so far so this is what we're
gonna do I have an Azure account open as
you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're gonna do so we're
going to create an application like this
which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application
we're just going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
thing is to create an Resource Group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it Azure simply learn right and
it's going to be a free trial and the
location pick one that's nearest to you
or you know wherever you want to launch
your application now for this use case
I'm going to pick Central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this example so
let's create a web app give it a quick
name let's call it azure
simply learn the subscription is free
trial and I'm going to use my existing
Resource Group a resource Group that we
created sometime back it's going to run
out of Windows and we're going to
publish the code offset we can create it
all right while this is running let me
create my database
right SQL database create a database
give it a name let's call it Azure
simply learn DB
put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some settings like the name of
the server and the admin login the
password that goes along and in which
location this is going to be created the
server name is going to be Azure simply
learn DB that's the server name and the
admin login can be what can be the admin
login name let's see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now Azure
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of uh or that's
in Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console we're going to go back
to visual studio feed these inputs in
the visual studio so the code knows what
the database is the the credentials to
log into the database stuff like that so
we're going to feed those information in
Visual Studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while we really got to be patient all
right now we have all the resources that
we need for the application to run here
is my database and here is my app
service there's one more thing we need
to do that is create and firewall
exception rule so one more thing needed
is to create a firewall exception rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the database right so let's
add an exception rule by simply adding
the client IP it's going to pick my IP
the ipf laptop I'm using as of now and
it's going to create an exception to
access the database so that's done now
we can go back to our Visual Studio I
already have a couple of
apps running or couple of configurations
pushed from a visual studio I'm going to
clean that up if you're doing it for the
first time you you may not need to do
this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to how you would be
doing in your environment all right so
we're gonna select an existing Azure app
service now before that I have logged in
as you can see I have logged in with my
credentials so it's going to pull few
things automatically from my Azure
account so in this case I'm gonna use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
all right we have clicked on Save and
it's running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an URL
now initially the URL is not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database that would
be the next thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my web app as of
now
it's going to throw an error like you
see it's throwing an error that's
because we haven't mapped the app and
the DB together so let's do that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server Explorer this is where we're
going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource Group right appropriate
Resource Group
which is right here
and here I have my database azure
simply learn database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application
right so let's go to the solution
Explorer click on publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my DB connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my DB now if you recall rdb was
Azure simply learned DB and that's not
being shown here so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure and here let's put
our DB servers URL now before that let's
change this to SQL Server
all right and then in here I put the DBS
URL so go back to azure
here is my DB or server's name
put that here
all right
the username to connect to the server
that's right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
azure
portal or the Azure infrastructure and
here is my database if you recall it's
azure
sldb that's the name of the database
Let's test the connection
connection is good click on OK
so now it's showing up correctly Azure
simply learn DB that's the name of the
database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is azure simply learn DB
and then it's going to be
SQL Server that's the data source the
username is simply learn and the
password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate the connection
it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish our application
again now the application knows how to
connect to the database we have educated
it with the uh the correct connection
strings the DNS name the username and
the password for the application to
connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an URL to connect
and anytime we put or we give inputs to
the URL that's going to receive the
input and save it in the database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and I can start creating to-do list for
myself all right so I have the items
already listed I can create an entry and
these entries get stored in the uh in
the database I can create another entry
and I'll take the dog for a walk that's
gonna get stored I can create another
entry uh book tickets for a scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how I can use Azure services to create a
web app and connect that to the DB
instance and how those two Services
which are decoupled by default which are
separate by default how I can you know
use the connection strings to make
connection between the app server and
the database and be able to create an
working app so if you're ready to embark
on this exciting career path look no
further than simply learns Catholic
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into the cloud
architecture deployment model security
and migration strategies a
terms like AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform to build your
Cloud expertise don't miss out on this
chance to transform your career and join
the ranks of successful Azure
professionals click the link in the
description to discover more about the
cloud computing course in this video
we'll go through Azure machine learning
in detail including its capabilities the
Azure ecosystem that supports machine
learning and the various ways we train
and build models
starting with
what is azure machine learning followed
by who is machine learning for
then we will look into its
infrastructure Readiness and security
then we will dive into machine learning
project workflow
following that we will understand
mlops devops for machine learning and at
last we will explore the Azure machine
Learning Studio
after that we will have a demo too
so without doing any further dealing
let's start with the video
so what is azure machine learning
Azure machine learning is a Cloud
solution that helps you speed up and
manage your machine learning projects it
can be used by Machine learning
Specialists data scientists and
engineers in the daily workflows models
are trained and deployed and mlops are
managed
you can use an open source platform like
Pi torch tensorflow or scikit learn to
build a model or use one created in
Azure machine learning
model monitoring retraining and
redeployment are all made easier using
these tools
but this brings us to a question
that who exactly machine learning is for
so individuals and teams deploying mlops
inside their company can use Azure
machine learning to move machine
learning models into production it is
safe and auditable environment
data scientists and machine learning
experts will find tools to help them
speed up and automate their daily tasks
tools for embedding models into
applications or services will be
available to application Developers
platform developers will find a strong
set of tools for constructing Advanced
ml technology underpinned by resilient
agile resource manager apis
now that we know the basics of azure ml
let's have a look at its infrastructure
Readiness and security
so Azure machine learning is an Azure
Cloud platform that adds security
to machine learning projects so
Integrations for security include the
following network security groups in
Azure virtual Networks
Azure keyboard is a world where you may
store security Secrets like storage
account access details
and set up an Azure container registry
behind the v-net
so now let's dive down deep and explore
its project workflow
models are usually created as part of
project with a specific goal and
objective
multiple people are usually involved in
these projects iterative development is
used while experimenting with data
algorithms and models
now coming to the Project Life Cycle
while the project lifespan will differ
depending on the project it will
typically look like this
a workspace space organizes a project
and facilitate collaboration among
multiple users who are all working
toward the same goal
users in a workspace May easily share
the result of the experiments through
the studio user interface
or they can use versioned assets for
jobs like environments and storage
references
so users work can be automated in a
machine learning Pipeline and activated
on a timetable or https request when a
project is ready for operation therefore
models can be deployed to the manage
interferencing solution in real time or
batch abstracting away the
infrastructure management that is
traditionally necessary for model
deployment
now let's proceed further and understand
the concept of mlops that is devops for
machine learning
mlops or devops for machine learning is
a process for generating models for
production use
if not reproducible the lifetime of a
model from training to deployment must
be auditable
mlops or machine learning operations is
based on devops principles and methods
to improve workflow efficiency
continuous integration delivery and
deployment for example these ideas are
applied to the machine learning process
by mlops with the purpose of
experimentation and model deployment can
be done more quickly and quality
assurance and end-to-end lineage
tracking are more efficient ways to put
models into production
now
let's explore what is azure ml Studio
so Azure machine Learning Studio is an
online service that includes low code
and no code alternators for project
development and asset management in
Azure machine learning
basically it is a workspace where you
can create build train the machine
learning models
for inclusive data science platform the
studio integrates no code and no code
first experience
so now that we have covered all the
important concepts of azure machine
learning
let's have a demo for a better
understanding of how machine learning is
used in azure
so let's start with the Demo First you
need to browse the Link studio dot Azure
ml.net and here you need to login with
your Azure account
so once you have logged in you will be
led to a new window
this is new window here you can see a
few options
so let's start and see one by one what
these options are
so the first one is projects
basically this gives you a list of all
the experiments that you have already
worked on so here you can see we haven't
worked on any experiment yet
then comes experiment
experiments are all the programs and
codes that you have worked on to create
it or deploy a model that you've just
created for an experiment
so as I said we haven't created any
experiment yet so the list is and I'll
over here
when you click on samples you can see a
few
sample experiments provided to you by
azure
portal by default
and following that we have web services
so we all know since Azure is a cloud
computing platform so all the data
gathered from our experiments needs to
be uploaded to the cloud so web services
gives you a list of all the experiments
that you have in the cloud so you can
access them from anywhere
so uh when you create an experiment and
work on it when you add it to the cloud
the data is stored here
so then comes data sets
it gives you all the data sets you have
in your Azure portal when you click on
the samples option
again you can see all this data sets
provided to you by default in your Azure
portal
then comes train models
so while working on an experiment you
will come across a point where you need
to train your model
so basically this gives you a list of
all the models that you have trained in
the experiments or Azure programs
and in the last com settings
any changes that you want to make to
your workspace is done under settings
here you can see uh this is your
workspace name workspace description
which is by default and all the details
is provided
here only so whatever changes you want
to make your workspace you will be doing
this over here
so now let's start with a demo
so down below you can see the ad or new
Option here
so click on it
and then you can see there are a few
ways templates provided by you provided
to you by Azure itself so we'll click on
blank experiment
once you click on the blank experiments
you'll be guided to a new experiment
window
so this is the new window and this
window is divided into three parts
these are the components
where you will plan your model
this is the canvas to design your model
and then the properties of the model
in the components section you can see
samples already present there so you can
select any one of them according to your
requirement so here when I'm typing
samples
uh
I'll work on airport codes data sets so
I just need to drag this option over
here
but before starting uh with our
experiment let's change the name
so here I'm changing it to airport
codes
demo model
so now you can see the name of the
experiment this changed
now when you click on it
and select visualize
just a second
you can see the number of rows and
columns provided to it the datas which
is required for its dataset to be
created and for its model to be created
so the four rows four columns are
airport ID city state and name
now we will move towards the part where
we Define field we need to make a
predictions for so type columns in the
search
bar
under manipulation section
you can
see there are multiple options provided
to you
so here we will select
select columns and data sets
as we are working on data sets
now connect your data set with this
option
so you can see a red alert over here
so
when you click on it
you can see it is asking for values in
your data set so to add values click on
the launch column selector under
properties
section
so once you click on it here you need to
select all the options needed for your
required values so for my experiment
model I need all these data sets so I'll
add all of these and then click on the
save option
so let me just add this
let's see now I have saved
all the values I need in our in my data
set
so now you can see the alert is gone
so now we have the data sets that we
want to work on so let's look for an
appropriate algorithm for it
so while looking into the classification
algorithm
we know that our
so here you can see it under
classification model we have
these options
so we know that the target value is
divided into two classifications so the
algorithm we will be using is a
two class
so we will be using two class booster
decision tree
because it calculates the accuracy for
every node and once the calculated
accuracy is more than a required
accuracy then only it moves to the next
node
so basically this gives you a prediction
value close to the accurate value of the
model
so we will just drag this option over
here
so now the next step we have is to train
our model
so we just need to type train over here
and select train model option
so
just drag it to the canvas now connect
the two booster decision tree to the
train model
now you can again see the red a lot for
a required data as it doesn't have any
data to work on so our next step is to
split the data
so we'll type split
and drag this play data option on our
canvas
as you can see this is also seeing
it needs an input Port data set so we'll
connect a data set with it so
that it is provided with the
data
so when you click on it you can see it
it is asking for a spec percentage
so you split the data into training and
testing where 80 goes to training and 20
to testing so we will mention 0.08 over
here
and
so now we will just connect the 80 data
up to the train model
as we said the 80 goes for training
but you can still see the alert in the
train model because it is not aware of
the column
it needs to train on
so we will click on
uh
launch column selector
now you just need to select all the
columns
you need to work on so I'm selecting the
airport ID number
now you can see uh once I save it
but the alert is gone
now our next step is to find the score
of a model so let's type score
in our search bar
and drag the score model over
here
let me just reduce the size of the
canvas yeah
so we will just connect our train model
to the score model
so
again you will see the Red Alert as it
doesn't know the data it needs to test
on so for that we will connect the
remaining testing data in the split data
option to the
score model
now you can see the alert option is gone
now coming to the final step that is
evaluation of the model so let's type
evaluation
and here you can see the evaluate model
option we just need to drag it to the
canvas
so
let's
connect it with our score model
now your model for the airport code data
set is complete so this is the whole
model now you need to save the model and
then click on run option
here I've saved it
and you can see it's running
you can see the model running and going
through every node
as you can see the green mark
as it's verifying through every node
so once it's done click on evaluate
model
and then click on visualize
now you can see the accuracy is a
98. here you can see the accuracy is 98
which is almost a prediction value now
you can see the positive and negative
labels as well
so this whole data is known as confusion
Matrix
now for the values close to the pos
positive label it gives me the number of
true predictions
that uh the number of data I'll provide
it will it shows that 72 predictions
will be right and one will be wrong
now let's go back and
run this model over the web
so by clicking on a setup web service we
will click on predictive web service
now we will just connect web service
input to the score model
so that once the program is uploaded to
the cloud it is directly connected to
the score model
and gives us the output
so now you need to save this
and run
this will execute the entire model now
all uh we are left with is deploying the
model
now
you just need to click on deploy web
service
so then you will see you will be taken
to a new window
here you can see
the response page where it's showing
test option you need to click on it
so here you can see a new window has
popped up so you just need to mention
the details like for City I am
mentioning Bangalore
First Data mentioning Karnataka
and name of the airport is
campagoda
International
Airport
and I just need to save this data
so now down below you can see it gives
me predictive values
and this is the airport ID
for my mentioned details
so the accuracy of this ID will be 0.98
which is 98 percent
which is almost accurate to the hundred
percent
so this was our experiment and this is
how we can use ml in Azure what is azure
active directory now here we're in a
situation where we have two colleagues
having a conversation with each other so
one of them complains that he is finding
a hard time managing multiple user
logins at the same time his friend
suggests that he has a solution that the
company start using as your active
directory he says that with Azure ad
they'll be able to handle multiple user
logins without any issue so just like
the question in all our minds the friend
asks how is azure active directory going
to help us so to help you understand
let's think about a scenario you're an
employee working for an organization and
you want to use a particular service in
this case SQL database so you are
assigned a set of username and password
then you want to use another service a
machine learning service again you're
assigned a different username and
password and likewise for any number of
services that you want to use so for
every service that you are going to
choose you need to be assigned a new
username and password but this becomes a
huge issue for the administrator as they
have to handle a large number of
username and passwords now if you think
about a large organization where there's
more than thousand people working you
can understand how much of a hassle it's
going to be for the administrator at the
same time it's also a really difficult
thing for you to remember that many
numbers of username and passwords it's
difficult on the user as well and that's
where Azure active directory helps now
here's a scenario where we're applying
Azure active directory now you're an
employee you want to use a particular
service and you're assigned a single
username and password and with this
username and password you can access all
the services that you want so there's
only one set of username and passwords
that you need to remember you can use
any of the services that you want as
long as the administrator has given you
access to it so what is azure active
directory now Azure active directory is
a service that falls under the identity
domain it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based directory and identity
management service now here's an ideal
scenario you're joining an office newly
the admin helps you sign up to whatever
Services you want and you can access
these Services anywhere over the cloud
so now let's talk about something
different Windows ID and Azure ID now
Windows 80 was the previous version of
azure ID so now we'll talk about why we
needed to change from Windows Active
Directory to Azure active directory so
what is Windows Active Directory now
it's a OS directory service which allows
you to work with multiple systems
multiple network resources in a unified
manner now the biggest draw when it came
to Windows ad was that it had many
layers now different layers that did
different bits of work so now let's talk
about each of these layers the first
layer is adds or the windows active
directory domain Services now each layer
as I said before has a different role to
perform adds allows admin to manage
information relating to user logins and
other details like when they sign up how
much they're using and things like that
the next layer is ADLs or the Azure data
Lake storage services this layer is for
allowing you to store any amounts of
data of any type or size then you have
the adfs or the active directory
Federation Services where you're given a
single option for sign up with which you
get access to all systems and
applications then we have the fourth
layer the adcs or the active directory
and certification services this enables
administrators to customize services and
then be able to manage and issue public
certificates and the final layer is
adrms or the active directory Rights
Management Service and this is used for
data protection now here's where Azure
active directory changed the whole game
this means that there's a large number
of layers that administrators need to
take care of now how about there was a
solution for this and Azure ad is that
solution Azure active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are the windows Azure
active directory or the the waad where
it combines all the problems when it
comes to identification management which
is almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows Azure Access Control
service enables the Federation or the
division of all these Services of an
organization and by division I mean
assigning each of these services to
these users so that is taken care of by
the windows as your Access Control
service hence as your active directory
is able to simplify a lot of the
problems that Windows Azure active
directory had for example the
application Office 365 uses Azure active
directory to manage user identities
here's how now you're an employee who
wants to access one of The Office 365
Services which could be Excel PowerPoint
Microsoft Word or something like that so
you go talk to the administrator and he
gives you access to these services with
the help of a single username and
password now as long as you have this
username and password and the
administrator has given you access to it
you can use any of these services so
who's the service audience who is using
the active directory service now there
are three types of audience when it
comes to Azure active directory the
first one is ID administrator the second
one application developers and online
customers so the idea administrators
their main emphasis is to ensure that
the sign-in takes place they take care
of all the sign-in procedures they also
solve issues when it comes to
authentication for example to
authenticate a particular user the
problem is solved by the it
administrators then you have application
developers who use these services to
develop applications and with this they
have a easier time developing
applications as all these resources are
easily available you have online
customers who make use of services like
Office 365 and other CRM services and
have all their demands catered
immediately so now let's have a look at
how we can use Azure active directory to
provide access to a particular
individual so if you log into the Azure
account this is what you see or you go
into active directory list of all the
people who are using or have been given
permission to use resources from Azure
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name which is John
and second name Jacob
now for properties we need to determine
the source of authority which is already
the active directory so that's fine we
can select a group or add them to a
particular group if we feel like it now
if we add them to a particular group it
means that they have access to all the
resources that everyone in the group has
access to earlier so we'll do that later
we'll select their directory role or we
can select it here if we need to it
could be user administrator or a limited
administrator and now we'll set up a
password so we already got one and we'll
create
and that's it we have created a user now
we'll go to their profile
so what we can see here is that you have
access to every bit of detail related to
this account so you have the name your
first name the username the object ID
job info everything you can even have
other details like how often they've
signed in when did they sign up you can
check their password you can reset the
password delete their account and so
much more
now we can even add a directory role
which we saw earlier and now let's add
this person to the admin group so you
know he gets access to all the services
those people have access to and select
that's it we've added them now the other
things that you can see here there are
applications licenses devices these are
all restrictions you can add or remove
like which device you can use the system
through or with and stuff like that so
that's it and with that we've created a
user and given access to certain
Services why should you be interested in
data Factory now let's consider a
scenario so here we have two colleagues
having a conversation with each other
and they say that the data that they're
generating from their applications or
products is increasing exponentially now
considering that this data is coming
from a number of different products
it'll be a bit of a task to analyze and
store all of this data so he wonders how
they're going to manage that his friend
suggests that they use azure's data
Factory now what does azure's data
Factory actually do first it stores data
with the help of the data Lake storage
now any kind of data can be stored in
the data Lake storage then you can
analyze the data you can transform the
data with the help of pipelines and you
can publish the organized data you can
visualize the data with third-party
applications like Apache spark or Hadoop
as well now what exactly is data Factory
so now let's have a look at what exactly
is data Factory now data Factory falls
under the identity domain of services in
the Azure catalog and is a cloud-based
integration service basically what it
does is it works on your data it stores
your data it orchestrates and automates
the movement or transformation of data
it works heavily on the data that you
store now let's see how it actually
works or how the flow of its processes
are firstly we have the input data set
which is nothing but the data that you
have within your data store the one that
you need processed then you pass this
data through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
for from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures or high now after this
is done you get an output data set now
this output data set will contain data
that is in a structured form because
it's already been transformed and made
structured in the pipeline stage then it
is given into Link services like Azure
data Lake block storage or SQL now what
it does is restore information that is
very important when it comes to
connecting to an external Source now
this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an SQL Server
you need to mention the source and
destination of your data now for example
consider an SQL Server so you need a
connection string so that you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
Link services work and finally you need
a Gateway now a Gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
or on your on-premises system so that
you can connect to the Azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like Apache spark R
Hadoop and so on so all this time I've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to Azure
data Factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
Lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
Frameworks which is external Frameworks
like Hadoop Apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the Azure
data Lake store and then it is provided
two external Frameworks like R Apache
and Spark so that they can be worked on
now there are two main Concepts when it
comes to data Lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data Lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the current the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the Azure data Factory
to move data from an SQL database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on Google it's called you just need
to Google it ssms the first thing you
can take here and there you have it so
you just need to click here and download
the file so we I've already downloaded
the file so basically this is used to
create a database which we will be
transferring to The Blob storage so this
will take about depending on your
computer speed pretty long or little to
no time I've already downloaded it the
process is very simple just directly go
on saying yes yes and finally once
installation is done here's what we're
going to do we should go into the
dashboard of Microsoft Azure we need to
create a data warehouse so we'll go into
all the sources Creator Source go to
database
and select SQL data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so I've already set
up a possible set of names
YouTube
it's free trial the source is already
created
a blank database the server will need to
create a new one so
we'll name it as YouTube server
YouTube
admin as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done and here we need to change how much
you want the lowest I mean how much
computation you want how much did
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and create
so now we're creating an SQL data
warehouse so we will wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and and go to the resource
here now this is done so we'll go to the
ssms which I've already opened here and
then go here
and copy this paste it here SQL
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is admin
YouTube admin and the password which is
also given there
right go to options we go to the
database name which is YouTube
everything else is there you need to
change it to tcpip
and connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
again we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier we've got a databases
and here you have the YouTube database
that we just created right click this
and add a new query
I already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name Clark Kent last name is Bruce
Wayne and the table that's created will
have these two rows so now we're going
to execute this there you have it two
rows have been affected so now let's
have a look at our table
um
let's secure this line and there you go
the tables here so now that this is done
we're going back into azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the storage
where the blob storage is going to
happen so we're going to storage
accounts and click on ADD so here it's a
free trial Resource Group is YouTube
storage account name is
that's all okay us performance is
standard general purpose you can do
locally since we don't need to be very
reliable at least for this one Advanced
just fine view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
which does not exist and okay
it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data Factory now so we go to all
services and search for data Factory
you press add
so here we'll
free trial use existing which we have
YouTube ecos and create so now we've
created a new data Factory
now we'll wait while it's been deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
we'll name it
description and once now
until now okay
all right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so so what you
need to do is select a secure Azure SQL
data warehouse so one second to previous
here we select Azure SQL data warehouse
go here
search for
source
media subscription free trial hey
YouTube server and the databases YouTube
you also need to provide your username
and password I've saved it here
YouTube admin
[Music]
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab next
and now for our destination so where are
we going to connect this to we're going
to Azure blob storage next
destination
subscription free trial and simply store
now we need to name our
name our storage path next although this
can be
passed on
so here's what we're doing it copying
whatever is inside this to the Azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the here's the visual
representation of what's Happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
now let's have a look if it's actually
worked out go to our database we'll go
into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
we've created a new one
and there you have it So based on the
container that you've named there it's
created a new one here so actually I
earlier created the name called simply
blob but as you can see here as long as
you name a container we'll create a
folder inside which you will find your
particular thing that you copied and
that's it you've copied data similarly
you can do a number of multiple
operations on this container on the on
the pipeline which is created with the
data Factory let's now move on to Azure
virtual machine
before that let's consider a scenario
Rachel had to host 10 virtual machines
at once per project there was an issue
when her computer RAM was not compatible
with the instances the computer RAM was
only 8 GB and the instances that
required were 10gb then she says I wish
there is a service that's cost effective
and also provides extra RAM memory one
of a colleague heard this and he comes
up with an idea he says can we use Azure
watching machine it has a pay-as-you-go
pricing and has this for storage you can
pay for what you use and create any
number of instances with high storage
capacity also if any technical
difficulty arises you can easily
retrieve the files through the backup
server so now she's happy and she wants
to know more about Azure washing machine
Azure virtual machine is one of the wide
range of services that Azure offers to
create your instance a virtual machine
is a computer file typically called an
image which behaves like an actual
computer it runs in a window giving the
user the same experience on a virtual
machine as they have on the host
operating system itself multiple
watching machines can run simultaneously
on the same physical computer each
virtual machine provides its own
Hardware like CPUs memories and other
devices as your virtual machine offers a
high range of flexibility and it
maintains the physical Hardware that
runs on it let me explain some of the
benefits of azure watching machine first
we have easy development and test as
your virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application next agility and scale Azure
virtual machine is agile and the ability
to clone and spin up multiple instances
of the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services and applications rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively as
your virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost as
your virtual machines provide extended
Data Center and can be easily connected
to an organization's Network it is easy
to set up your redundant infrastructure
in Azure and Azure provides a full
Disaster Recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore let me explain
Azure virtual machine components in
details virtual machine comes under the
compute domain of azure it also offers
various services like availability sets
snapshots disks images and many other
services like hosts virtual machine can
be clubbed with other services like
disks images availability sets hosts and
many more so the first component and the
most important component is the
operating system the operating system
creates connections to the remote
desktop session host there are many
operating systems available like Ubuntu
Red Hat Linux Windows Server sent OS you
can also set the operating disk size so
that the memory is not wasted the next
component is disks as your watching
machine use attached virtual hard disks
for storage take two types of virtual
hard disks first is an image it is a
template for creation of new Azure
virtual machine then we have disks it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
disks are backed up by Page blobs in
Azure storage therefore the disks
inherit the benefits of blob storage
High availability durability and many
more the discs are mounted as drives on
the VM the next component is virtual
Network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate Network spaces for
internet facing and back-end servers
load balancers firewalls and more many
of these components are deployed into an
Azure virtual Network as your virtual
Network provides many features such as
subnet IP address load balancer and
Network Security Group
another important component of azure
virtual machine is availability sets if
in case there's a slight chance there
could be a failure in physical servers
then these come into picture so in case
of such failure the Azure platform will
migrate the failed virtual machine to a
healthy host to reconstitute the VM it
is highly recommended to deploy at least
two instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what Azure virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this Demo First we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into Microsoft Azure with your
credentials now let's click on Virtual
machines and create a new one
so I can put add
and you can use the subscription you
want either pay as you go pricing or
free tile Resource Group will create a
new one that is pre-roll
one
okay virtual machine you can create I'm
going to use VM web
and then region I'll be using Okay East
US
then image I'll be using Windows Server
R2 Data Center
size I'll be using B1 MS
select
username and admin
and then password of your choice
and then I'm going to allow selected
ports and choose rdb3389
and next
so always this step I'll be using
standard hdv
and then
yeah next
so I can see a default virtual Network
and a default submit in public IP as
well as default
and then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
I'm going to select an extension to
install and I'm going to install
Microsoft anti-malware
create okay
I'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so I've created Five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
watching machine and see our virtual
machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the IP address
then hit Windows plus r
and open mstsc
and
paste the IP address and connect
this is a difficult
you have to use the administrator
account that we've created before with
the same password
click ok
now the remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next
select role base of each of these
installation and click on next
then select the virtual machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server IIs next
sorry
so it's already installed my computer
but you have to install this
then let's close this
and open Internet Explorer
let's type in
http
localhost
yeah so now we can see the default was
opening let's minimize this
and let's try it here
we have just put the IP address
I think there's an issue
okay so let's add an inbound Port
networking select networking and add in
one port
let's move forward 80.
and add
okay so it's added now let's go into
fresh it
now we can see the default web browse
opening so the next step is to modify
the web browser let's go ahead with that
go back to your remote session host
let's go file explorer
so certain folders are created from the
C drive let's open that
it would be under eyelid Pub
because this is where the default is
coming from now let's make a new text
document
open that and put
hello
welcome
to this demo
by simply learn
save it
close it let's rename this as
index
dot HD sorry
Mill
so this is a text document
so we need to change that
okay let's remove this
okay
that's done
now let's go back to our Internet
Explorer and hit F5
let's refresh this
let's try and okay so let's
yep so it's done now let's go back to
the previous browser and try let's
refresh
yeah that's done so if you're ready to
embark on this exciting cardio path look
no further than simply learns Catholic
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into the cloud
architecture deployment model security
and migration strategies I
sounds like AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform to build your
Cloud expertise don't miss out on this
chance to transform your career and join
the ranks of successful Azure
professionals click the link in the
description to discover more about the
cloud computing course first of all
let's look into why is azure virtual
Network important
so why Azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity time
consuming process and building Network
topologies could not divert Network
traffic to its destination on time so
these were a couple of challenges the
company was facing so the employees
thought that what could be the possible
solution to these challenges
and then we require the Azure virtual
Network in that case so first of all
let's understand what is azure virtual
network is an Azure v-net or a virtual
Network represents your network or
environment to run VMS and applications
in the cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
Internet so virtual Network you can
consider it as a virtual Cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud space
virtually assigned to the users or or to
the organization which they can
dedicatedly use for their purpose so for
example if you have to create some
instances or virtual machines onto the
Azure cloud
and you want to connect it with the
on-prem servers for example uh then you
might require the virtual Network in
that case let's assume that those
instances that are created in the
virtual Network require the range of IP
addresses that you want to allocate to
them and that is something you can
customize using the Azure virtual
Network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed to your instances in the
virtual Network how the firewall
Securities should be applied everything
the end user can control in the virtual
Network so it seems like that you are
working in your own data center ideally
you would be working on to the Azure
Cloud using the virtual Network
now what are the advantages of using the
Azure virtual Network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as I said that
it feels like it seems like that you are
working in your on-prem environment that
means within your data center but
ideally it is a virtual space that is
allocated to you which is a kind of an
isolated environment and that is
specifically designed for your tasks and
the activities
are generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
Network which can access the public
internet so there is a public network
connectivity that is enabled in the
virtual net so that a subnet which will
be created in the v-net can be accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control lists defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented High network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the Azure
Network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated Network
topologies in a simple Manner and which
is easily manageable as well as there
are less troubleshooting issues that we
would encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual Network
one of them is the subnets
then you have routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the major or a
prime important component in the virtual
Network so what you have to do is first
you obviously you would be creating a
virtual Network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning or virtual partitioning
inside the
virtual Network
subnet lets user segment the virtual
Network into one or more sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every Department there
should be some set of IP addresses that
you want to allocate to the machines
that the employees are using or all the
department should be isolated that means
that they should have their own network
IDs and the network addresses are
located to their machines and in that
case what you would do is you would
create the subnets and the subnet IDs
that would be allocated to those
departments these sub networks can be
separated logically and each subnet
consists of a server so what you do is
when you create a subnet you can you can
create a server or an instance inside
that subnet and how do you want to give
an access to that instance depends on
criteria or the requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on how the
public subnet should be interacting with
the internet and for the private subnet
as the name suggests that the internet
is blocked so that means it is
completely isolated in the virtual
Network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the NAT gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggests public instances that public
subnets that means they have the direct
internet connectivity next component is
routing and the routing is primarily a
routing rules you can say that are
applied and those are actually applied
to the routers only so since on the
cloud we cannot have a direct router
access and hence using the routing as a
component we can Define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router in the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet Azure virtual Network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
Network automatically a route table is
created and that basically is required
to router traffic and that can be used
by every subnet that doesn't mean that
you only have to create a single route
table in the virtual Network you can
have multiple route tables also created
which can be associated with different
subnets as well then you have the
network security groups it is kind of a
firewall that protects the virtual
machine by limiting the network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
Network traffic depending upon the
destination IP address port
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances and uh or virtual machines and
they basically Define that how the
traffic should be reaching to the ports
onto the virtual machine so how do you
want to open up the ports and for which
IP addresses you want to open up the
ports that is something the end user or
the administrator has to specify our
design so they act as a kind of a
firewall rules only that protects the
virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
v-net so first of all you have to create
a virtual Network so virtual Network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual Network then you would be
creating subnets which are considered as
a subset within the virtual Network
so Cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first v-nets are created then
the subnets are created and then you
configure the properties in the security
group
have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual Network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual Network in the Azure
cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual Network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual Network so you can
create one as a public subnet the other
one has a private subnet for example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual Network
for which virtual Network you're
creating an instance within that virtual
Network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created and then connect instance to a
relevant network security group so
attach your network security group to
the instances and based on the
properties or the rules that are defined
in the network security group that will
be applied to the instances within the
subnets finally configure the properties
in the network security and set the
policies as a result you will be able to
launch your instance on Azure within the
virtual Network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create Azure virtual Network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there to watch our demo on
the Azure virtual Network in today's
session I would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on Microsoft Azure and here you can see
on my screen that I have already logged
in into the Azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual Network you can type and
search in the dashboard in the search
bar with respect to the virtual Networks
and here you can find
the virtual Network and the gateways so
what you need to do is you just have to
click on the virtual networks and then
it will give you the options to add the
components inside the virtual Networks
so let me first open up the virtual
Network
right now in theory we discussed that
the virtual network comprises of
multiple components and sub-components
so primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual Network then you have
to assign the ipv for cidr Block to the
virtual Network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual Network along with that you
define the routing rules and likewise
you create the instances inside the
subnets that will be part of the virtual
Networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so I would be adding up a new
virtual Network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
v-net which is by default so when you
created the Azure credentials the demo
virtual network was already created by
the Azure so that it can provide you the
default settings and then the test one
has been created by me and that's the
customized one or you can say a
non-default virtual Network
so I'll I'm going to add another v-net
and
would Define
the name to it so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual Network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
Group so what is a resource Group it is
primarily a collection of resources that
share the same lifecycle permissions and
the policies so if you have a resource
Group created you can use it otherwise
you can create a new Resource Group so I
already have one that is the demo one I
would be using that in the instance
details you have to specif the name of
the virtual Network so these are certain
uh parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say I
put something like test v-net
as the virtual Network that I want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created so these are the available
regions that you can select I would go
with us East
us only and then we have to define the
IP addresses also
see so in the IP addresses uh these IDR
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed IP
address for that v-net so what you can
do is you can specify a range of IP
addresses now whenever we talk about a
virtual Network and the IP addresses we
primarily focus on the private IP zoning
so this is the private IP that we are
actually talking about so I can reserve
some IP address cidr for our v-net and
that is the range of 40.0.0.0 16. I'm
going to reserve so now we'll create one
subnet and we'll name that subnet so as
we discussed that subnets are the sub
components of the v-net
so here you can see we have already
created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and let's name it to something like demo
subnet right and the subnet should have
the IP address range and that IP address
range should be part of the v-net owned
in vtn so same subnet address range you
would be defining in the subnet as well
so that will be 40.0.1 dot or we can
select 2.0 slash 24.
the rest of the things would be default
we are not attaching any route table as
of now so just click on OK and here you
can see that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we'll go
to the search bar and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test we net
and inside the demo subnet so that our
virtual machine gets the private IP
address from the subnet that has been
created in the v-net itself so what you
need to do is you have to open up the
virtual machines click on ADD
and here you should add a new virtual
machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and the network details
where we would be defining the v-net as
well as the subnet where the virtual
machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free trial and in the resource Group we
will go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name uh something like test VM
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also now in the networking we would be
selecting
the test we net as our virtual Network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet so that is the recently
one added in the test we net and we want
that our virtual machine should be part
of that subnet only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public IP also
assigned since from the public network
we need to access those virtual machines
so we'll keep it enabled right and the
next uh would be the default settings
that we are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and then
create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
v-net and it gets the private IP address
from the subnet that has been part of
the
v-net which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine so let's
wait for a couple of more minutes and
we'll look into the status of the week
now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that our virtual
machine is created in a correct
subnet or not and that is something
which we can validate by checking the
private IP address so it got the private
IP from the range of the IP address that
we have specified in the subnet now in
order to access this particular virtual
machine you have to use the public IP
since uh since we have to access it from
the internet so from the private IP this
virtual machine will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public IP address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
the virtual Network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other and that
actually creates a kind of an isolated
environment on the public Cloud which
gives you the understanding that you can
work into uh just like in on-prem
environment only so let's get started
Azure devops Azure devops enables teams
to organize work collaborate on code
development and build and deploy
applications using developer Services
Azure devops the culture and set of
protocols that brings together
developers project managers and
contributors to collaborate on software
development it enables businesses to
create and enhance products more quickly
than they could with traditional
software development methods you can use
Azure devops services in the cloud or
Azure devops server on premises
Azure devops has built-in functionality
that you may access via a web browser or
an ID client depending on your business
needs you can use one or more of the
following standard owned services
Azure repos Azure devops a built-in
functionality so for sourced management
of your code Azure reports offer git
repositories or team Foundation Version
Control
Azure pipelines build and release
services provided by Azure pipelines to
assess continuous integration and
delivery of your applications
Azure boards using kanban and scrum
methodologies Azure both provides a set
of agile tools for planning and tracking
for code bugs and issues
Azure test plans manual and exploratory
testing and continuous testing are among
the options available in Azure test
plans for testing your applications
and at last Azure artifacts this allows
teams to share packages from public and
private sources including Marvin npm
nuget and more and corporate package
sharing into their pipelines so this
brings us to the features of devops
first we have is dashboard control you
can rapidly navigate to different
regions of the project build and manage
dashboards and set dashboard widgets
using the devops dashboard functionality
then we have improved Source control git
and team Foundation Version Control a
centralized client server system which
are two prominent methods of source
control supported by Azure devops
solution to observe change history you
can add and manage Azure git tags
reviews downloads and modify files
following that we have plan and track
your work you can utilize Azure devops
systems to track features requirements
user stories tasks issues and more using
a variety of work items then we have
integrated collaboration servers Zoom
that allows teams to collaborate
throughout the whole Azure devops
feature set including team dashboards
project Wiki discussion within work item
forms and many others then we have
support for exploratory testing manual
exploratory and continuous testing are
made easier with Azure devops which
include workflow customization
end-to-end traceability criteria based
selection and real-time visualization
that show the test activities and at
last comes continuous integration and
deployment many developers use CI CD and
Azure devops makes it so easy to do so
developers May automate various design
activities with Azure pipelines
including defining and Building
Association steps writing test
instructions and managing simultaneous
releases well this brings us to Azure
devops services
you get an integrated set of services
and tools with Azure devops to manage
your software project from planning to
development to testing and deployment a
client or server model is used to
deliver these Services many of them are
offered via a user-friendly web
interface that works with all media
browsers The Source control Bill
pipelines and work tracking are just a
few of the services that may be managed
to a client you can see the left pane is
where to access Azure devops Services as
demonstrated in the figure below so now
that we have covered Azure devop
services
let's move on to Azure devops server
Version Control reporting requirements
management project management automated
bills testing and release management are
all capabilities of azure devops server
a Microsoft product it provides devops
features and spans the complete
application cycle so now that we know
what Azure devops services and Azure
develop server are so let's have a crisp
comparison between them to know how
exactly they differ from each other
despite the fact that Azure devops
service is a hosted version of azure
devop server there are seven features
that differ some functions of azure
develop server aren't available in Azure
devops services
so when deciding which platform to use
or considering a transition from
on-premises to the cloud keep the
following points in mind cope and scale
data authentication users and groups and
manage use access so first is scope and
scale data Azure devops services and
Azure devops server are slightly
different
organizations and projects are currently
the only alternatives for scoping and
scaling data Azure devops Services
organization get their own URLs and
always have exactly one project
collection whereas deployment project
collection and projects are the three
methods for scoping and scaling data in
Azure devops server then we have
authentication to connect to Azure
devops services using the public
internet depending on your
organization's Arrangement you can use
Microsoft account credentials or Azure
ad credentials to login you can also
configure Azure ad to require
multi-factor authentication IP address
restriction and other security features
but you connect to an intranet serving
using Azure devops server Windows
authentication and active directory
doming credentials are used to login so
this method is completely open and you
will never be asked to sign it next we
have users and group you may use a
similar technique to Grant access to
groups of users on Azure devops Services
Azure ad groups can be added to Azure
devops Services Group so you must add
users one at a time if you utilize
Microsoft account instead of azure 80.
on the other hand by adding active
directory groups to multiple Azure
devops groups you make chance user
access to deployment in Azure devops
server the membership of AD groups are
kept in sync so users gain and lose
access to Azure devops server as they
are added and withdrawn in Erie and at
last there is manage user access to
manage access to features in Azure
devops and Azure devops server by
signing users to an access level each
user in your Azure devops Services
organization must be assigned an access
level as usual as Visual Studio
subscriber sign-in Azure devops Services
verifies them so without a visual studio
subscription you can give basic access
to five users of coffee whereas all use
of azure devops server is on the honor
System specify the access levels on the
administrative Administration page to
set access level per user based on their
license and assign unlicensed user
stakeholder access only so now that we
have covered all the important features
and concepts of azure devops now let's
move on to the next very important
aspect of azure devops which is azure
devops lab
the Azure devop lab is a place where you
can learn about software developments
and operations with Azure devops
Services you can simplify and speed up
the devops process it explains how to
use Azure devopservices to automate
software delivery and satisfy business
requirements so to understand it in a
better way let's have a demo of azure
devops lab so let's start with our Azure
devops demo so first what we need to do
is navigate to this
website Azure dot microsoft.in or we can
directly login through dev.assure.com
also the first what we need to do is
sign into a Microsoft Azure account
so after
signing in
will be led to this page in that
you just need to click on continue
and here what you need to do is create
an organization under which you're gonna
create your projects multiple projects
and you're gonna attach your team
members to it or group members to it
whom you want to get the access to your
projects
so what is the difference between
organization and project is if you have
given anybody access to your
organization or somebody is a part of
your organization then
then that particular individual will
have access to all of your projects but
if you have given somebody only access
to a project then you'll be only
restricted to that particular project
you won't be able to access any other
project that is present under that
particular organization that you both
are part of so basically organization is
something that is used to connect to
groups of or related project or somebody
who's already a part of a particular
organization so here we will give it a
name so I am giving uh simply
demo as the organization needs and here
you can see that the projects under this
organization will be hosted under the
South India region
and you need to enter the captcha
and click on continue
in just a second
so now you can see this saying that it
is taking you to an organization
okay so we already have an organization
of the same name so let's just change it
to something else
let's give it simply demo
org
so here you can see that I see this
thing that it's taking to your Azure
devops organization where you'll be
creating your projects
so now you can see your organization
name
here
and here you just need to create the
project name
I'm giving it to
simply
Gemma
project
not below you can see the visibility we
can opt either public or private so what
is public or private so basically if uh
you keep its keep the project off keep
the visibility of the project public
then once
you copy this
URL
so as I was sitting once you copy this
URL into some other browser or incognito
mode you will be able to have the access
to the project
but if you keep its visibility private
then only the people who have real
access to your organization or to your
project will be able to access that
project or will be able to see that
project or work on it
as you can see public products are
disabled for our organization so we
can't
select public so we'll go for private
and click on create project
now here you can see
the home page of your organization where
you have
this project
and here you can access the statistics
of project how it is performing how much
time you have contributed to it or what
all services you have added to your
project
and down below you'll be able to see
that there is just one member which is
the root user of this project and once
you start adding more members to your
project it will their details will be
added to this particular
block
so now here you can see these other
services both the ports pipelines test
runs and artifacts services that is
provided to you to add to your project
so now let's have a look
at them one by one
so first one is votes
as we click on boards you can see
multiple options your work items ports
padlocks Sprints queries delivery plans
here you can see it is all empty as we
haven't added any service or we haven't
worked on a project yet
let's just click on
new work item
so here you can see one is epic issue
and task
so epic is an option that is uh you can
see a pro auction
for work items
so basically epic represents business
initiator to be accomplished and it is
basically available for basic agile
scrum and the cmmi process templates
so what it exactly does is increases
customer engagement that whoever
whatever your project is if it's
uh the engagement
of your project that how it's performing
and how it is performing towards the
people
whom you have given access to the
project also helps to create new
architecture to improve the performance
of your project
and it also support mobile application
so basically when you're deploying any
mobile application in your project or
creating a mobile application as a
project so it will be able to
support that as well
let's click on it
so here you can see you need to enter
the title for your
epic option
so where you need to add the title of
your epic link for say
we are creating a healthcare or an
e-commerce application so obviously it
will be segmented into different parts
like you'll be having search options or
Support options or home page so we just
need to give it a name
and where you can see its state is to do
for now we just have to do because we
haven't
actually created anything in our project
and we haven't given any input
so it's in to-do list and once we start
working on it it gets we can change the
state it it can be in progress or
completing so there are multiple States
for your Epic
and here you can see the area is simply
demo project that means that we want to
assign this
search you know Epic into this project
and we can also click description over
here that what exactly our new epic is
about like for search options we need to
specify or give a description that
this is for searching options related to
our application like for healthcare one
can type
medicines or
doctors
or slots
so
that is that that is thing that we can
add in our description
that it will help the user to understand
what this feature is about
so this was epic and once done we can
click on Save
so here you can see other
starts also like priority
so we can select priority according to
our
will so here by default it is probably
two
so priority basically is which function
will come first
and here you can mention start date
Target date
so once it's done you can click on Save
now let's move
to the next one
second what we have is issue
so basically issues are the for you that
that's your work
and the epics are used to track the
group work under large scenarios but
this is that like like we saw the
project statistics so it will help you
to understand the individual progress
so basically issues are raised when you
find any obstacle in your
progress or in your work so it can be
compared to impediments also so when
you're working with agile uh
you need to deal with issues so by
default we have agile
to our project assign
so like for example we can see that uh
we have a meeting so during the meeting
members report if they have encountered
any bug or any any impediments
so what next we have to do is we have to
track them and resolve it so these are
the issues that can uh one can find
like possibilities
so you can assign here
and give it a description again
and just save it so
once a user faces these issues
we can keep a track of it
and
once it is raised we can resolve it
coming to the
next one
next we have is task
so by the name only we can uh well
understand what task is
so a task is a smaller item or
smaller segment to track activity
that contains all the information needed
to accomplish a part of a of an issue or
you can say user story requirements so
this option is available for basic agile
scrum and cmmi process templates
so again we can give it a name what task
we want to assign
and give it a description
and according to that we can
select the priority
and save it
so the task will be added to your
project
we are not for assigning any tasks right
now because as I said we haven't added
any uh particular
project or particular details or
application or we haven't deployed any
application yet in a project so
that is why we are not adding anything
over here again because first we need to
understand what these services are and
what these services are used for
next we have backlogs so backlogs helps
you
to understand the flow of your project
like today you have contributed 10
percent
of your time and you have completed the
10 of the work or you have worked on
certain segments of the project like for
say you have worked in the support area
so it helps you to understand and keep a
track of the flow of your project how it
is performing and how it is developing
and how it is built every day
thank you
next we have a string
so Sprints are basically a time box
intervals that support set team's
ability
to work using the agile processes and
tools so what you can do is whether
you're having let's say you're having a
healthcare application so you just need
to
have a segment of it and drop it over
here
so what would what it will do is uh it
will get the attention of all the team
members so basically what it does it it
makes your project more manageable
it increases the quality of your project
and also makes it work even more faster
and more frequently once you add the
segment to the Sprint
so you can see it in one week that's the
priority and people need to work on it
and it gives the project more
flexibility to adapt to change
now now sometimes what happens is many
Associates drums prints with agile
software development
so sometimes
agile often thought to be the same thing
coming to the next one we have queries
so the queen page basically remembers
the view you have
last navigated and when you log in again
or when you come back again
the same portal it returns you to that
very particular view only
so it can you can say that it runs with
Azure devops command line interface
and all the open uh like all the pages
that you have gone through you can keep
a track of it over here
you just need to click over here all and
you can just see all the queries you
have
uh Define in all this while and also you
can share the queries with the team
members
so they can also know that where you are
when working lately
or which segment you have been working
on or what was the last navigation
which you have been going through in
this whole project
so it can help you manage your project
in a more efficient way
and keep a track of how and what all
segments you have been working on and
what else segments you need to work on
in your project
coming to the next one we have delivery
plans
so here you can see uh we haven't
created any plan yet so basically
delivery plans are a calendar view of
multiple teams or theme backlogs or
individual backlogs from different
projects
so basically it replaces the delivery
plans Marketplace extension
and it is only available for Azure
devops services
so here you can hack you can or you can
say it's a summary or a Time summary of
all the projects you have been working
on in a particular organization
so now that we have covered both uh
let's
move to the next one which is repose
so with the name itself we can well
understand that repo stands for
repositories so basically it is a set of
repositories that allows you to console
and manage your project code
like for saying you're deploying a
healthcare application so
these Repose options
help you create repositories and
manage your code of that particular
application and more efficient way
so what you can do is you can connect
project solutions by using the repos
link
as you can see here it is shown
so let's look into its option one by one
first we have
files
so in files your project solution will
be available in this section
so
repositories can create manage and
import those Solutions
okay so you just need to upload your
Solutions of your code or your project
Apple
just create repositories for it and it
will help you free manage those
Solutions in a better way
you can see who is here
clone to your computer portion existing
repository from command line and
imported repositories if you want to
import any solution like here you can
just
click or import and add the solution
towards the processary
so this is what files do
basically you can see It'll say it is a
it's like a physical folder itself where
you have all your
name files or repositories or Solutions
you can say of data
so basically it's it functions like a
physical folder itself
so it helps you keep a track
your codes and everything
next comes is comments
so uh in comment section we can manage
commit history
for your repositories that you have
created in files
so it just commits those repositories
with author details from branches like
for say we have a theme one from
spot branch and one from management
branch so
whoever creates that repositories and
have the solution it commits that
repositories under that under that
particular member of the team
with the branch name
then comes pushes
so Bush histories are available in this
section
from each pull request done by the
developers Developers for sale the team
members we who have been working on this
particular project and creating
repositories and solutions
so what is pull request
so pull request or PRS are a way to
change or a review of merge code in our
repositories
so basically teams uses these PRS to
review code and give feedbacks or
changes whether like uh for say you are
deploying a code or a solution
so one can review them what all changes
needs to be named or what all
upgradation needs to be made or whether
the code is already fine or not
so basically teams use these years to
review the solutions and codes stored in
these repositories
or you can merge multiple Solutions or
multiple codes into the main branch
so basically the viewers can step
through the proposed changes and leave
those comments and what to approve or
reject that particular code
or you can say to upgrade or what are
changes you want to make it they vote
for it that whether that needs to be
made to that particular solution or not
so these are the TRS
next we have branches so we can manage
multiple branching information in this
particular section you can create create
or release branches from Master to death
okay so all users
can actually
can actually create or release branches
from branching information available in
this particular section
next come
that
tags are used to point out specific
comments
like uh giving message tags and these
information to branches you can create
your name in conventions to branches by
using submit tags
and the second the next one is pull
request which we have already discussed
the PRS that are basically used in
pushes
completed Repose also
so let's move on to the next one which
is pipeline
so here you can see see that we don't
have any file pipeline
creative for us yet so let's have a look
at it
provided options one by one
the first one is environments
so basically it is a collection of
resources where you are actually deploy
your application that you're working on
so it content you can say it contains
one or more virtual machines containers
web apps Etc whatever uh resources you
have actually used for deploying your
application
or what are Services you have used for
creating the environment for the
deployment of your application of course
say we need to deploy our application
and it needs an uh
windows
Java environment so whatever resources
you need to create that environment that
will be added to this environment list
it will be listed over
this section
next we have releases option
so basically this pipeline stores the
data of your pipelines or stages
or tasks
and
deployments in Azure pipelines that in
departments you have done so far in your
applications for your applications
actually
so you can say that uh it helps your
team continuously deliver software to
your customers at a past pace with a
very minimum you can say lower risk
so it you can fully automate and
automate the testing and the delivery of
your
software or applications on multiple
stages
or you can also set up an automated
process with approvals and on-demand
deployments
then comes
Library
so again you can see the page is black
so from the name itself you can
scrutinize that it will be a collection
of assets from
Azure devops projects
so basically it is a collection of build
and release assets of a particular
project
assets defined in a library can be used
in multiple bills and multiple releases
pipelines of the project
so all assets that are defined you know
Library share a common security model
so you can control who can Define new
items in a library and you can use an
existing item that you have already
added in this Library
so those are defined for I library items
for say you have added a particular
asset a particular item to this Library
segment
and you can assign a particular member
who will be working on this item
okay so the rules are defined here for
these and these governs the operation
you can perform on those items
that person will be keeping track
whatever changes have been made or
whatever upgradation has been made to
the particular item that has been added
to this
segment Library segment
so then comes uh task groups
so
standardize and centrally managed
deployment steps for all applications in
your projects
so when you include the task group in
your definition and then make a change
centrally to the task group the changes
automatically reflected in all the
definitions
so we can conclude with this that a task
group allows you to encapsulate a
sequence of tasks already defined and
you can say build or release Pipelines
or into a cycle task group
so it just encapsulates all those
sequences tasks
so you can choose to extract the
parameters from those encapsulated tasks
as configured variables and
abstract the rest of the task
information
so what happens is the new task group is
automatically added to the task catalog
and it is ready to be added to other
release and build Pipelines
task groups are stored at the project
level are not accessible outside the
projects group so the task groups will
be only limited to the members who you
have assigned in this project and it
won't be
accessible to the other people or other
team members from different projects
even though they are the member of the
same organization so you can say it's
more of a private
second
now that we have covered transcripts
next we have deployment groups
so deployment groups are only available
with classic release flight Pipelines
and it is totally different from the
deployment jobs
it is basically a collection of
deployment related steps Define in a y a
ml file to accomplish a specific task
so
in nutshell it is a logical set of
deployment Target machines that have
agents installed on each one
the deployment groups represent the
physical environment for example testing
or development of production environment
so a Development Group is just another
grouping of Agents much like an agent
pool you can say
so what you can do with this is you can
specify the security context and runtime
targets for the agents or you can let
yourself use live logs for each server
as a deployment take place
or you can also enable you to use
machine tags to limit deployment to a
specific set of
servers
so this was about deployment groups now
that we have covered one more service
let's move on to the next one that is
test plans
so
test plans the first one we have is
progress report
so you can
analyze with this only the progress
report will be the progress of the
project you have been working on or the
deployments you have been doing or the
tasks you have been performing
so
basically it lets you analyze and view
data for
more than one or an individual test
plans in a particular project
data for test plans can migrated can be
migrated from
and on-premises Azure develop server
that won't show up in this report
okay
so basically this section lets you drill
down by each test plans and give you
summary of each test
plan in it the section also lets you to
navigate to a test plan or shoot of
Choice by double clicking on it okay
so this was the progress report next we
have runs
so basically if she presents the
execution of Pipelines
continuing a run the pipeline is
processed and agents process one or more
jobs
so when you run a pipeline many things
happen under the couple while you often
won't need to know about them
occasionally it's useful to have the
bigger picture right
so
Azure Pipelines
will get processed under this
test runs
segment so you'll be able to see the
water performance
is happening over here like while you're
running a pipeline you can see uh
designing state
the the date you have started that
or what all that
returning pipeline increase like jobs
steps and tasks
runs power both continuous integration
and continuous delivery Pipelines
much we have load test
so basically as your load testing is a
fully managed as Azure service that
enables developers and testers to
generate High scale load with custom
Apache Jane leader strips and gain
actionable insights to catch and fix
performance bottlenecks at scale
basically application performance and
resiliency are more important than ever
before
so how you can run an Azure devops test
so first you need to click on it and
select a test suit that contains all the
automated tests
and you can just choose the run test
option
and it will start processing it so the
service this service basically simulates
traffic for your application you can say
regardless of for on which platform or
where it is actually hosted
so now that we have covered test plans
as well let's move on to the next one
that is artifex so this is the last
service that is provided to a project by
azure devops
so artifacts is a
byproduct produced during the software
development process
so it mainly consists of the project
source code dependency or binaries or
resources that could be represented in
different layout depending on the
particular technology
so it's like an extension that makes it
easier
to discover in stone or publish
and Maven packages in azure devops
it's basically deeply integrated with
other hubs like build so that package
management can become a seamless path
for your existing workflows
so what is exactly it is used for so it
basically it can be used
for both public and private organization
with teams of any size it it basically
manages your
npm or new get packages via feeds and it
allows you to create and share your
makeup
it's a package management solution
all about the services that is provided
to your projects so now that you know
what our service is
do for your project and what are their
benefits and how they function now you
can actually plan your project and start
creating and working on it and start
deploying with the users and what all
services you want for your particular
projects so what you can do is click
here on Project settings
just a second
yeah you can just click on Project
setting
so now what you can do is you can add in
description that uh what your actual
project is about because I like I said
if you're creating in a healthcare
application so you can just give it a
description that it is for him scare
related to issues employees and helps
needed and like you're trying that
particular application is different
possibles or Healthcare organization so
you can actually add those information
in this description
and the process which basically it is
basic or private one
but you do get a range of process
for your project when it depending on
the visibility of it like for HR or
strum you can say
so now here you can see that only my uh
ID is attached to it as I'm the only
member here and I'm the administrator so
add members here
scrolling down
now that you know what all services uh
provide you or what they provide to your
projects depending on the need of your
project you can just
so select the services you want to
assign to your particular project like
per se if I don't want both assigned to
it or if you can say if I don't want the
services provided by the coach you can
just click on it and select remove both
and I just need to refresh it
here you can see I have overview repos
pipelines
artifacts but I don't have uh test plans
and Boards as you can see test planning
is basically all the collection of
whatever you're managing which is
indicately assigned for both
so as you remove the both of the test
band also get removed okay
once
like this you can just uh select what
are Services you want specifically and
if you want to delete your project you
can just go ahead and delete it
so this was all about
Azure devops services and I'll show the
robot the studio you can see
the demonstration of how a project
actually functions in UV wrap up with
Azure Basics if you like this video hit
the like button consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss updates from Simply learn
till then keep watching and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign